[Music]  in 2021 we faced record acute global  hunger and malnutrition  now situation may get worse  russia's invasion of ukraine sent shock  waves through global food and energy  supply chains  the international community must act now  to avoid the largest food crisis in  history in the short term we must  provide immediate assistance to save  lives and prevent famine  in the medium term we must support the  transition to sustainable aqua food  systems and in the longer term we must  address the drivers of food insecurity  conflict climate change poverty and  inequality we are committed to combat  food insecurity  [Applause]  you